this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking a look at the weapons
from the 2023 remake of Resident Evil 4
which also has a fair few new guns the
good old MP5 they've done a much better
job than Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2
slightly more irksome and it's making me
want to reach for the emotional support
weapon this is the fact that some
Heathen has apparently cut off the front
sight of this poor MP5 we've done a
range of videos on the weapons of
Resident Evil including looks at seven
the original version of four and Village
so make sure to check those out and of
course let us know what other games or
guns you'd like to see Jonathan
breakdown in the comments section below
right let's take a look at the weapons
from the remake of Resident Evil 4.
definitely H and K pistol appears to be
based on the USP and I guess the USP
match but the compensator is much more
integrated into the design than the
match with its extended muzzle device
well see how it works but I think we've
got a fixed fixed front sight muzzle and
a effectively a split slide type design
otherwise it's pretty faithful to the to
the USP I think the important thing is
the overall impression is of a real
pistol and it makes you think a heifer
and Croc if you know what's what the
pistol is so it's been it's been changed
up a bit that fits with my memory of an
experience actually of some of the
Resident Evil games of how they they
inspired pretty closely by real things
but they do add a bit of a flourish some
significant recoil there on that pistol
I'm not sure if it's supposed to be in a
larger caliber like 45 or well 10
millimeter might be the only thing that
might make you might cause that amount
of muzzle rise if you especially if
you've never experienced or lack hand
and forearm strength or something which
clearly our man here does not on the
other hand he is using a less than
optimal hold bit of a bit of a Jack
Bauer going on I think probably because
he looked like that in the original game
and because it gives you a bit of a nice
over-the-shoulder view that shows you
the weapon in all its Glory third person
Glory
fn57 this is a quite intriguing firearm
we have a couple we don't have the
different variations it's it's evolves
slightly over time we don't have one
with a desert tan frame penetration and
recoil are two things that we've seen
here in in these clips so that the
vendor there is talking about how
penetrative of the cartridge is
penetrate just about anything
uh which which it is relatively speaking
even the standard sort of ball load is
relatively going to penetrate further
than a lot of other handgun cartridges
with the trade-off of a smaller Hull
essentially produces a smaller hole in
the Target but it's a small diameter
bullet traveling very quickly creating a
a small hole in the Target now it's not
traveling fast enough to create the sort
of second order effects that we see with
rifle true rifle cartridges so it is a
specialist handgun cartridge or
submachine gun cartridge famously for
the P90 submachine gun but suffice to
say the game for a game is getting it
right in terms of it goes through more
things or one thing deeper as it were
and then low recoil so relatively small
bullet low bullet Mass it's easier to
control and we see that with this
shooting at this pole here that it's
recoiling way less than the HK pistol
and the shot the resulting group not
controlling not trying to compensate for
recoil resulting group is way shorter
and way narrower in in terms of width
two aspects of realism in a game that is
really not about realism but it's always
fun and the representation of the five
seven is pretty pretty damn close maybe
a couple of tweaks
all right shotgun looking great I have
to say design wise
substantially Remington 870
um I think as before it's got a barrel
rib an extended tube magazine under the
barrel and maybe some hints of Mossberg
500 or something else I'm not seeing the
rounded bolt of the 870 substantially I
think it's a Remington 870 um as I think
it was before looks good sounds good
exactly what you want from a video game
shotgun but it's punchy the sound sounds
great the effect on target is um
dramatic on these zombies but it's a
very video game shotgun though in that
the spread is excessive the spread is
kind of cartoon Blunderbuss which which
is B with a barrel like that this
distance is shown I don't think would be
possible you'd be looking at a sort of
fist-sized Hull with a typical duck shot
load at those distances absolutely
devastating it with a real shotgun as
well but not this this incredible cone
of Destruction that we see here taking
full advantage again of the third person
angle so as well as the shooting we get
to see Leon sort of angle it over almost
for the camera and load the tube
Magazine from underneath like this
before bringing it back into the aim the
sort of sort of thing you can't do with
a first person view
right so an iconic Resident Evil
especially Resident Evil 4 handgun the
vp72 it looks to me like they've based
it more on their original own
interpretation than on the real gun I
was kind of expecting what I would
regard as an upgrade graphically to look
more like the real thing and actually
looking at it the detachable shoulder
stock slash holster does look more
baseball I remember lots of extraneous
detail ribbing and weird angles and
stuff that were on the original but
stocking in the in the original game so
they've changed that up and made it
closer to the real thing still not a
great match for the real thing they're
the selector switch on there it's not
the same shape as the one on the gun so
this pistol cannot fire in burst unless
the stock is attached I'm sure some of
you know that we'll see if that's
reflected in gameplay and then the
pistol itself I mean you can see it it's
broadly right in fact that form of grip
without the thumb shell as it were it
does exist the trigger is not as
distinctive on the game version and it's
more like a 1911 trigger but it does
have the upper curve doesn't have the
bottom curve let's have a look at it
right straight into the gameplay with
the stocked vp70 and it is firing in
three round burst but having been
fortunate enough to shoot one of these
things it fires at a much much higher
rate in reality it's uh it sounds gonna
sound silly but the word the word would
be brang
it has this weird resonant kind of
quality and it's like a single sound
it's like three shots so close together
and very distinctive that it's like they
happen at once uh Minor Detail this
Sia here this auxiliary Seer that or
sort of actuator I should say pops up
when you go from semi to burst that is
modeled in the game so in third person
view it's all it's there it's always
there because this thing is just burst
only when it's the stock attached but
that detail is there the game is an
interesting blend of bits of realism and
quite an overall realistic feel for the
Firearms but with Liberty's taken they
don't let the rears and get in the way
ever which I think is certainly one way
to go uh and a great way to go if you
want to prioritize people enjoying the
game and not obsessing about nerdy gun
stuff
foreign
this is a Legacy gun from the original
game it's the h k sl8 now this is a
civilianized version of the G36
automatic rifle Assault Rifle it's the
same gun but due to due to the gun
having a substantially polymer
construction it was very straightforward
for h k to come up with a completely
different stock for it that makes it
look like a completely different gun and
that's what we get here so a fixed but
thumb hole stock gives the with us with
a short magazine and a scope gives it a
sort of pseudo DMR feel and that's kind
of the niche that it occupies in this
game with that scope a new feature is
the ability to remove the scope and use
the iron sights it's going to be better
for close-up shooting in reality I think
he would just look over the top of the
scope and fire almost a reaction style
if you had to or you would have an
arrangement where you can still use your
iron sights which does exist depending
on the scope mount you can still look
down and see through the iron sights and
then you have the best of both worlds
without risking affecting the accuracy
of the weapon by removing and replacing
the optic
right the other well there might be more
but the other stocked pistol in in this
game we've got here in fact well let me
show you in its stowed form this is the
the red nine version of the brim handle
mouse or the c96 I'm sure you know this
but the red nine usually red not always
sometimes it's inlaid with black
sometimes it's not in late at all
um this denotes nine millimeter
Parabellum the Luger Pistol cartridge to
differentiate for the German Army in the
first world war from the quantity of
original 7.63 Mauser c96 is that they
already have and it's a it's a later
form of the c96 so it's industrial
compared to the really nice late 19th
century version but it's still an
incredibly cool well-made sort of hand
finished
pistol as they pretty much were of that
era this version of it is looking good
the version of the game is looking very
sort of gray but it's done it's done
well um it looks like where these guns
that have been handled shot used
probably gone through a war so it looks
pretty realistic for that clearly put
quite a bit of love into making this
look
pretty good
all right so I haven't fitted the the
butt stock uh to this one but having put
a number around through these they are
so much more controllable with the butt
stock fitted and that's true any stock
equippable pistol um it's giving you
multiple points of contact suddenly you
go from something that's trying to do
this to something that can't do that
your shoulder's stopping it your cheeks
on the on the buttstock as well it's
incredibly stable recoil control is it's
just not a problem at all with either of
the the cartridges that this is
chambered for you can fire rapidly and
accurately and at greater distance and
all of that it turns it into not a not a
true carbine obviously but a pistol
carbine and it is way more capable but
it's it's a trade-off you know do you
want the butt stock fitted to turn it
into a sort of not very good rifle or do
you want to try and use it as and I love
these things but I'm not very good
pistol
right this is a pretty iconic Resident
Evil 4 weapon I distinctly remember from
the original review uh multiple names
for this this one's an arm cell Striker
there was a scaling issue with some of
the guns in the original original
Resident Evil 4
um the broom handle for example was far
too big uh this gun was far too big it's
actually very small and compact one of
it's perhaps few positive qualities the
scaling is better the details good it's
very close to our example here this
great big housing on the side that's
missing from our gun is on versions of
this gun so that's not incorrect A lot
of the detail you really have to look at
the detail of say the pattern on the
grips to start nitpicking this thing
something that's still glossed over so
we're using the loading X load that's
that's good what's still glossed over is
the comedy you know like world's
deadliest alarm clock loading or speed
system it is Clockwork 100 clockwork
this is a revolver drum it's a it's a
straightforward revolver shotgun in that
respect
break already
this is a very interesting gun because I
don't remember this model being used in
the original and it's significant here
because this is meant to be a powerful
Magnum revolver you can see the thing
kicking like anything and creating
massive damage the gun they've very
Faithfully modeled here is the Smith
Wesson Scofield a variant of the the
model 3 revolver which is top break as
depicted top break revolvers aren't
great for Magnum cartridges because
they're putting a gun under a lot of
force that is trying to split it apart
and break the latch so that's a that's a
problem and the Scofield is very much a
black powder era cartridge revolver and
so those two things together I mean the
44 magnum cartridges won't even fit that
cylinder I don't believe off the top of
my head um but if you could somehow size
it up and make it fit well I guess you'd
be making a brand new gun with model
steel that happens to look Schofield and
somehow is able to I mean I'm sure you
could do it I'm sure you could engineer
a modern copy of a Scofield revolver
that can somehow take the pressures of
the 44 Winchester Magnum but if this is
meant to be an old west Schofield the
rounds I don't think the rounds would
fit and if they did they'd blow the gun
to pieces
foreign
First Impressions on this and obviously
it's the much the same gun as the
original game two Inspirations I think
though one is the the Terminator B
Terminator 1984 movie with the huge
laser sight on the top of the gun that
actually they had to run a wire down
Arnold's sleeve to a battery pack on his
belt to operate then because they didn't
have the miniaturized power supply yet
so it's ahead of its time uh and now
it's behind I think his lasers are much
much smaller and lighter and less
obtrusive anyway so the visual profile
is of that and then you have the laser
in the gameplay the other inspiration I
suspect is the lar Grizzly that's in
well a number of calibers but 45
Winchester magnum so it's a 40 like a 45
Auto cartridge but more powerful
obviously the ammo pulls in this game
are shared across different different
guns so it doesn't quite work in that
respect and the design of the slide
doesn't quite work with the grizzly but
it does have the square trigger guard of
the grizzly and the Magnum power level
of that as well don't think the original
gun from Resident Evil 4 had that
trigger guard on it so possibly a modern
inspiration so a bit more realistic than
you might think
foreign
so we all know this is the RPG 7 a
faithful looking model looks good to me
no obvious issues with it unlike the
gameplay where and this is probably a
bit of a carryover from the original
game or maybe just a sort of ethos of
big guns having lots of recoil in the
game although giving it a single shot
that wouldn't affect gameplay anyway
what I'm rambling towards here is that
the recoil is well it shouldn't beat
with the coil The Recoil the rpg7 is a
recoilless weapon first and foremost has
a rocket assisted munition there's
something that's gone horribly horribly
wrong if your recoilless weapon is
recoiling over your shoulder like that
so that's completely wrong and probably
the biggest issue I would have with the
game having said that they don't do this
slow traveling smoke Trail Warhead thing
too badly so so the the way the effects
are depicted is perhaps more realistic
than certain games
foreign
they've done a much better job than Call
of Duty Modern Warfare 2 did remember me
whinging about about that some some
major Liberties taken with the design
for whatever reason there are some taken
here you'll see the push pin here at the
rear for this assembly that's it nearly
all the way out that's missing from the
rear of this gun Minor Detail in the
scheme of things slightly more irksome
um and is making me want to reach for
the emotional support weapon is the fact
that some Heathen has apparently cut off
the front sight of this poor MP5 luckily
being a somewhat modular design someone
could replace this whole site block and
restore it its former glory but what's
weird is what I think is meant to be the
modular site base is actually just the
mounting point for the hand guard that
is not where you would want to mount a
site you could do it but why not do it
on the cut off site base that you have
cruelly inflicted upon this for creature
it's a slightly weird choice but overall
it's a decent MP5 I appreciate the fact
that it has more correct detail than
um Call of Duty does
[Music]
foreign
slap in there which is nice it's maybe
not as emphatic as it ought to be a
little bit subdued he's giving it some
sort of hit but uh he's not just
flicking it out of the notch with his
thumb but somehow it's not quite as
satisfying as it could be for me
otherwise the handling is pretty much
what you what you want from an MP5 raise
of fire is about right we've now got
attached to that length of rail on the
upper receiver a classic ACOG the ACOG
is still still widely used low
magnification Optical sight even though
for power optic on a submachine gun is
arguably Overkill but hey when you're
one man army getting a bit of a
magnified view it's probably not a bad
thing the MP5 is nicely accurate for a
pistol caliber so you could I think you
could definitely make use of the ACOG
whether you would yeah calibration in
terms of reticle for nine millimeter
ammunition is another thing we have to
assume it's all set up correctly
okay we've got a an AR-15 I'm not sure
of the the sort of if there's a fixed
time setting for this game it was of
course it was current ERA I think or
current year when um when the original
game came out now we're now it's
effectively retro but this gun is
somewhat retro this would be to be
correct for you know late 90s early
early 2000s time frame A2 m16a2 era
features uh that's the cartridge case
deflector the pistol grip which actually
looks weirdly a bit too big here but
that might be might be my my eyes I
don't think I can nail this to any
particular cult model it's pretty close
to an m933 which is the 11.5 inch barrel
baby brother to the M4 sort of but the
barrel here is a bit longer than that I
don't think it's quite any one real
world cult model
firing again
all right that's unexpected we have a an
artillery piece or a cannon if you will
not very closely based on any real world
gun it's the bore is huge uh it has tiny
multiple rifling grooves there's some
some earlier rifled Canon do the loop on
the rear on the the caskable button very
minor uh detail but uh that's that lends
it the appearance of the British
Bloomfield pattern of gun so this was an
improvement
um coming into the Napoleonic era and
that that specific feature was to do
with you put a rope through it and use
it to help to help to help set the gun
up essentially speaking of setting the
gun up there's no recoil show with this
so quite apart from the magical
attachment or gun crew that would need
to be swapping this thing out and
ramming a charge and ramming of a shop
or whatever it is you're shooting out of
this thing we're just gonna pretend that
they're you know that's been somehow
done off camera even though it's a
muzzle loading gun just just the
depiction of how it fires is is quite
off because something of that nature has
like if a handgun has this much recoil
in the game that Cannon should be on a
recoiling carriage or just a wheeled
Carriage that rolls to the rear and is
then reset by the crew and of course
none of that happens it's just magically
recoilless uh which is not not possible
there's room for improvement there but
I'm very excited to see it in a game and
used in a way that illustrates the power
and importance of artillery on the
battlefield you know the small arms are
insignificant compared to artillery I
just enjoy them more I'm afraid
look at you okay guys those were the
guns of the Resident Evil 4 remake which
I am increasingly excited about actually
I have to try and get my hands on that
having missed out first time around I
know controversial as a throwaway zombie
related question for the comments
perhaps my favorite zombie t-shirt I'm
an absolute zombie enthusiast
um does anyone know what this is from
answers in the comments otherwise check
out the Royal armories Channel and our
social media channels and we'll see you
again on this series next week